du drame il reste ces scellés posés hier
soir après les premières constatations
la victime avait soixante dix ans un
horticulteur à la retraite
père de trois enfants c'est sa fille qui
l'a retrouvé dans sa maison dans la
matinée le choc dans le village qui l'a
vu grandir la commune perd l'un de ses
piliers
quand j'ai appris la nouvelle hier matin
c'est vrai que ça m'a coupé les jambes
quand même comme on dit depuis qu'il
était à la retraite
il s'investissait beaucoup pour la
commune et c'est lui qui me livrer le
sapin pour faire noël sur la place qu'on
était sur la place et enfin oui voilà on
aura beaucoup de souvenirs de ce
monsieur des traces de violence des
blessures par balles une enquête pour
homicide volontaire a été ouverte par le
parquet d'auxerre
ce matin la brigade de recherche de sens
et celle de dijon menait les habituels
enquête de voisinage qui était-il
comment vivaient-ils quelles étaient ses
fréquentations
peut-il y avoir un lien avec les
événements survenus dans la région ce
week end notre victime monsieur kerckhof
connaissez l'homme qui a effectivement
été mis en cause pour des faits de
violences et de vol avec usage d'une
arme
anaïs ce week-end les deux hommes se
connaissaient oui
par contre je ne peux pas à cette heure
vous dire qu'il existe un lien entre les
faits commis à neuilly dimanche et le
décès de monsieur kharkov
des auditions sont en cours à l'heure
actuelle mais aucune garde à vue pour
l'instant
une autopsie sera réalisée demain pour
déterminer les circonstances et l'heure
du décès